Vsauce Kevin here and happiness is
depressing there is no more seminal
human concept than the pursuit of
happiness a nation was built around the
right to do it and even the
international Brigade of wine moms
insists on living laughing and loving
but people are miserable and it's
getting measurably worse the data on
pursuing happiness is in and it's not
good and it's not just an economic thing
Nobel Laureate Daniel Kahneman found
that even if we all had exactly the same
level of income our differences in life
satisfaction would be reduced by less
than five percent and trying to increase
social status correlates with depression
anxiety and mental illness life
expectancy is higher technology is
advancing rapidly on paper we should be
happier than ever we never been so sad
we're doing it all wrong and no one
cares
here's who invented happiness as we
think of it
yeah
cap is Old Norse for luck or chance and
English text on a y to mean full of so
happy is literally full of luck this is
really important to understand and
happiness a history Darren McMahon
writes that in every Indo-European
language without exception going all the
way back to ancient Greek the word for
happiness is a cognate with the word for
luck happiness today has almost nothing
to do with that and our corrupted
version of it is a constant desire okay
so what things are supposed to make you
happy knowledge Love Money food status
respect Beauty talent I asked you what
matters over 50 000 of you responded
with love money and knowledge winning by
a lot so here's how happiness is going
in games primates play Dario
mistrippieri writes that there is no
correlation between knowledge and
happiness people who are clueless about
themselves and the world can
nevertheless be very happy a 2022 study
showed up to 85 million Americans suffer
from politically induced fatigue
insomnia loss of temper and impulse
control problems and 12 million people
reported thoughts of self-harm a machine
learning meta-analysis of 43 studies
involving over 11 000 couples revealed
that nothing not age wealth education
values or anything else could predict
how happy two people in a relationship
would be Robert Jervis writes that when
people fall short of expectations of
themselves they're less happy and when
they exceed them they're more happy
suggesting that relative changes to
wealth matter more than wealth itself
half as many teens today meet up with
their friends every day compared to when
I was a kid the CDC reports since 2009
the percentage of teens who say they're
persistently sad or hopeless has risen
from 26 percent to 44 and a
meta-analysis of 258 studies showed that
searching for extrinsic validation
through status attractiveness and talent
recognition actually drives depression
anxiety and general Psychopathology
whatever it is we're doing is not
working we have a global self-help and
personal development industry that costs
us 40 billion dollars a year and which
is projected to grow at five and a half
percent compounded annually so people do
care about the problem but about 117
billion people have lived on planet
Earth for a few trillion combined years
of Human Experience so why aren't we
already amazing at happiness well we
were better at it but here's some more
research
real quick this video is sponsored by
private internet access VPN browsing the
internet with an unencrypted connection
is like sending a private message to a
group chat everyone saw your terrible
farting on metal folding chairs meme
with private internet access VPN you can
protect unlimited devices by hiding your
IP address and safeguarding your
internet connection through an encrypted
tunnel it works on all platforms and
it's particularly amazing at unlocking
region restricted content on streaming
services like Netflix so shows and
movies unavailable in your region are
suddenly totally available in your
region browsing without private internet
access VPN is like running naked through
the streets with your personal data
tattooed on your most intimate parts and
the best part is you can get it
risk-free with a 30-day money-back
guarantee so click the link below or go
to
piavpn.com vsauce2 to get 83 off that's
just two dollars and three cents per
month month and four months for free and
thanks to them for sponsoring vsauce2
Matthew Lieberman social revealed that
having one friend you see on most days
increases happiness as much as earning
an extra one hundred thousand dollars
per year and even seeing a neighbor is
worth sixty thousand being married
another one hundred thousand good
physical health four hundred thousand
dollars his research suggests that
despite Elon Musk being literally tens
of thousands of times richer than you
he's not forty thousand times happier
and we are terrible at judging other
people's happiness Kahneman showed that
we think the wealthier are three times
happier than they really are and we're
frequently wrong about others because of
the focusing illusion we tend to think
about their problems more than they
think about their problems look I know
you've got a few objections here and you
should because some people have really
bad lives maybe you do and it's really
hard to be happy and there's a causation
correlation issue at play like a decent
income puts you in a position to live in
a nice neighborhood be in Better Health
and have more time to hang out with
friends and seriously the concept of
happiness is linguistically tied to luck
in virtually every civilization ever for
a reason some people are just born with
fewer problems than others for better
and worse we all start as passive
victims or beneficiaries of probability
Victor Frankl got dealt some really good
cards and took some really bad beats few
people in the history of the world
should have been as unhappy as Franco he
was brilliant as a teen Sigmund Freud
asked permission to publish one of
Frankel's papers and he was publishing
in professional journals before he was
20 but in 1942 he and his family were
sent to a series of Nazi concentration
camps terations thought Auschwitz and
Dakota his dad died of starvation his
mother and brother were victims of the
gas chamber and his wife died of typhus
and Bergen Belson prisoner number
119104 made it out alive and the whole
time he thought about happiness what it
is and how to do it everything can be
taken from a man but one thing the last
of the human freedoms
choose one's attitude in any given set
of circumstances to choose One's Own Way
despite losing everyone he loved some in
malevolent horrific fashion and facing
his own mortality by the minute
Victor Frankl found meaning we know how
to be happy and no one cares about that
well they care about happy but chasing
happy doesn't lead to happy in the
Paradox of pursuing happiness the
authors concluded that the intense
valuing of Happiness predicts short and
long-term negative consequences and
greater levels of loneliness the people
obsessed with finding happiness were
less likely to achieve long-term
happiness and psychological well-being
we don't even use the word anymore that
gives us the best shot of feeling
happiness in our lives eudaimonia it's a
state of human flourishing it's Living
Well given your own unique set of
circumstances but we're so confused
about understanding unimonia that it's
often mistranslated simply as happiness
but that's wrong it's not happiness and
it's not even the pursuit of happiness
happiness is the byproduct of the Living
Well the side effect of human
flourishing in every step we take
towards the goal of Happiness takes us
further from eudaimonia a word we lost
for whatever reason
somewhere along the way
less than a year after the war Victor
Frankl published Man's Search for
meaning anonymously he wrote it is the
very Pursuit of Happiness that thwarts
happiness
Victor Frankel seemed to figure out how
to live well
can you and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
thank you thank you